[Music]
hey our video of the day comes from Bill
marah's Club random podcast where he
clashed with Neil degrass Tyson over
wokeism Tyson brought up how Mah no
longer performs on college campuses
asking if marah was writing off an
entire Generation by refusing to change
his act Mar was having none of that from
this inflated sack of pomp roll
it so is why is it their fault and not
your fault surely there's a portfolio
jokes still work on a college campus
surely I would hope not from what may
maybe some college campuses the ones you
read about are insane you've given up on
an entire generation and you don't know
how to make given up on any place that
doesn't even remotely attempt to believe
in free speech and thinks that anything
that that they hear that they don't like
that they don't agree with is violence
these people are nuts and you should be
calling them out somebody like you who
has standing with kids you're doing what
parents do you're taking the path of
least resistance and therefore hurting
the kids and yourself parents ruin both
their lives they ruin their spoiled kids
lives and they ruined their own lives
because the kids rule the roost so
that's what you're doing on a national
level
yeah guy you know I think he nailed it
but I felt like he didn't go far enough
because NE the grass Tyson he's a nerd
that finally found status and he can't
let it go he always wanted to be cool so
way of being cool is basically bowing
down to the woke and marah is basically
calling him on it yeah and I've been
finding myself rooting for Bill Mah more
and more recently which is an odd
feeling I'm getting more used to it over
the last couple of years but in this
matchup it's easy like Bill Mah for sure
and to scold him to his face that way
was satisfying and I guess the demand is
that Bill Maher must change his act in
order to be welcome on these campuses
and not offend people I think I think
it's I'm not a comedian you guys are I
feel like it's like a principled thing a
principal thing not to give up your act
to satisfy these little Tyrant blo
Hearts so marah is like both I think mad
about this he seems quite angry about it
but he's standing up for something that
matters a lot so I think some colleges
that are willing and eager even to have
their students open their minds and
maybe laugh a little bit and maybe even
learn something they should go out of
their way to invite marah and change
nothing just come and do what you would
do anywhere else yeah he's uh what do
you make of this I felt like he nailed
it it feels like on that side of the
world the liberal world the adults have
left the room yeah and their progyny are
now Frankenstein monsters Cut Loose yeah
they are monsters sorry I mean and
they're inflicted on the world after
they leave College yeah and so you know
what's interesting they believe in free
speech until they disagree with you so I
think really what degrass Tyson was
saying was Bill M you should do go out
there and do you know do something for
Humanity and talked to college campuses
and Bill m is saying what are you doing
you're not challenging them you're not
standing up to how they think you're not
challenging them on their lack of
knowledge of history and uh and I think
it really put Neil degrass Tyson back on
his heels I mean he's an astrophysicist
talking about Free Speech I'm not sure I
should listen to that I think the guy is
like Pro puberty blockers and he's like
he he he uh manipulates science to back
up just the dumbest wokey ideas Jamie
also I mean this is something you could
understand Tyson comes off like a
divorced dad trying to be cool around
his son's girlfriend yeah oh
um I love Bill Mah and I love this
podcast but tell me there's something
about it that makes you feel like he
doesn't know they're
filming like I don't know if he knows
it's being recorded it just to make a
small clarification I started comedy
performing at colleges and and and
they're he Bill Mar is not saying like
oh I'm going to go and like not do well
with my material they're going to tell
him what not to do
at the tell you exact what to do and
what not to do so it's notar he's like
oh people are going to get upset they're
saying like you can't come here if you
say that and if you do you won't get
your you might not get paid like it's in
your contract so it's a little bit it's
a little weird I remember being it's
been sort of like this for 25 years and
it's just worse not I remember going to
a college and you always had to be kind
of like squeaky clean and you couldn't
you know you had to be politically
correct I remember one time going in and
a girl coming up to me and going like
hey for our show I know a lot of college
campuses like you're not supposed to
swear she goes it's different here she
goes we want you to use the FW these
kids love it if you get crazy say
whatever you want I was like oh my
goodness so I went up and I go this is
like a regular show I'm like at a club
tonight and I destroyed and I swore and
I did like my club set and I was like
yeah and I got off stage and this
there's always like a student in charge
you know and then like there's always
like an adult who's like the
administrator he comes up and he goes
great sea you were like way dirtier than
like we had we had thought you were
going to be and I go I know but like
your girl told me that like this school
life's at and he goes I have no idea who
that
is
[Applause]
nice it was just somebody that was at
the show somebody just wanted to screw
you over cat if uh would you ever go
perform at a
college yeah I mean I would but I don't
know that people would love
it I I yeah I I I'm also Bill Mah is
like very very rich so he would like
there why would he be doing that anyway
yeah um but I think that you know we
talk about this a lot on the show about
sharing the risk right and I wrote in my
book actually about how like I'm not a
religious person but I know the book
Leviticus in the Bible is like not a
chill one it's pretty like fire and
brimstone right it's like um but even
that talk about sodomites yeah they do
even that one is like even that one says
an eye for an eye right and when we talk
about comedy these days nobody could
honestly tell you one of the worst
things they've been through is hearing a
joke that they didn't like or they were
offended by but there are people who
could say one of the wor things they've
been through is saying a a joke that
people were offended by so I feel like
if we're less chill than Leviticus and
the way that we approach this there
might be something we might need to
examine very well put thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else